that you're dating a loser if he is
flaky ghost you vanishes or is
completely
unreliable oh haven't we all met this
type ladies now this is such a classic
scenario especially you know haven't we
also met so many women who are like oh I
love him so much so she basically
accepts that type of behavior or she
puts up with it because well I don't
really have anything better going on for
myself well I kind of like this guy you
know you see what I mean there is no
excuse for a man to be unreliable or
flaky I need to tell you one thing that
well that usually just means he doesn't
like you or he's yeah he's got other
options on elsewhere yeah he's kind of
but ironically that behavior despite
what she's saying often that behavior
will attract women more because it's cuz
you got that element of of not knowing
where you stand right